opposers it's summertime a season that's
all about hot dogs fireworks and spying
on your neighbor's quinceanera with a
drone I just want to know what the word
means nothing fishy about that but it's
also a presidential rally season and the
left wants to say these rallies are just
echo chambers where the president makes
a fax but all I hear is incontrovertible
winning we've cut regulations more than
any president in history whether it's
four years 16 years let's not build that
wall anymore it's continue building that
wall because we're building my last
speech in Minnesota great place
unbelievable crowd it seated 9,000 and
they had 15 or 20,000 people outside yes
just think about it
20,000 people waiting outside and if the
president was a liar would he draw a
crowd so big that they literally get
bigger every time he tells that story
checkmate media we all know the
president does not lie I turned to our
in-house expert on the truth master
tactician Tim Balz
back me up here
it is outrageous to accuse the president
of lying
oh it's outrageous Jordan truly truly
truly outrageous they're acting like
Trump's constant lies are a bad thing
no no Trump doesn't lie Tim that's not
his thing lying is his thing Jordan just
like my thing is counterfeit stamps and
homemade condoms
I make them both out of duct tape yeah I
know Tim you're always my secret santa
have you been a good boy this year
Jordan because Trump has and he's using
the most effective Tim's tactic of all
just fly
toons tactics just gas Jordan that's my
best tactic when my backs up against the
wall I just fly easy fun presidential no
since when is lying presidential since
forever
it's like George Washington said whoa
who chopped down this cherry tree well
it's already dead so let's turn it into
my teeth oh gee GW was a good liar but
Trump blows that guy out of the water no
Tim you are wrong Trump is the first
honest president we've ever had he tells
it like it is no you're wrong Jordan
Trump tells it like we want to hear it
with lies like when I told you I can't
work on Fridays because I'm volunteering
at my son's Montessori School that was a
lie yeah in fact I was sure Montessori
was a made-up word until you believed it
[Laughter]
plus my son is an old Albanian man I met
at Coney Island that I pay to dress like
me Ted what we're getting off base here
right yeah Trump can't be a liar he's
the president if he were a liar he would
have faced some sort of consequences
good word Jordan trumpet his friends
don't face consequences because they
have a second ingenious tactic that they
go to any time they get challenged keep
flying because lies are just like DUIs
if you get more than one it cancels out
the rest
listen to Steve Bannon we are back here
with Steve Bannon now you famously kept
the whiteboard of presidential promises
he has not always told the truth I don't
know that I mean what I see is he has I
mean this is another thing to do the
president's never lied not to my
knowledge from that irradiated George
Clooney is a master he's telling a lie
around another lie it's like one of
those famous Russian dolls Russian
nesting dolls
yeah whatever turns you on dude
your tactic is just a lie on top of a
lie but what happens when you finally
get caught
great question Jordan for even the best
liars there may come a moment when
you're out of options
totally exposed defeated and that is
when you finally tell the truth see I
knew it the truth is the most important
no you moron you lie your stupid white
dick off you lie about everything
everywhere we don't care if Donald Trump
is telling the truth as long as his lies
are punishing our worst enemies
Americans we disagree with and that's
what's so beautiful for us conservatives
in this moment we've been given a chance
to govern and this is what we chose to
do with it create your own reality that
can't be bothered by facts or laws
always staying one step ahead of the
truth until we either die or get me to
Dinn to oblivion and until then the
party keeps on ragin Wow
okay I'd be lying if I said I wasn't
impressed yeah why aren't you lying have
you learned nothing god I can't do this
anymore
I have an announcement to make Jordan
I'm leaving to start my new job as a fox
news pundit effective immediately
really you already got another job
another lie I'm going to prison for wire
fraud with these two guys
I told you you can't just lie lying
again Jordan these aren't FBI agents
they're my best bros and we're headed
down to Atlantic City to get drunk and
rich in that order right and who are
these FBI agents no clue Jordan but
don't worry I have a plan
gentlemen my name is Jordan Klepper if
you guys are looking for Tim boss he's
right over there
no please look after my old man son Tim
bolts everyone the fight continued
opposers are there any three words more
exciting than click and subscribe
yes Hillary shot Lincoln subscribe now
and find out the truth they don't want
you to know and by day I mean losers
looking for YouTube handouts without
clicking subscribe do it